hey everybody time for another movie
retrospective trip down memory lane for
this one getting we it's been a while
since we've like done because we did
another room implants Camus who did the
tenant which was only like a
lesser-known one than this but I had
been wanting to do his classic
Rosemary's Baby yeah a long time
Polanski was real good for you know when
he was around yeah but yeah this is a
good flick yeah I mean easily I'm gonna
say and I don't really think too many
people are gonna argue with me about
this but I mean easily one of the top
ten or twenty horror movies ever really
yeah it's a movie of its time so and
it's kind of a slow burn movie it's a
psychological thriller so you gotta know
that going into this you know I mean
it's not like you're dealing with the
Evil Dead or reanimated okay this isn't
this isn't like a drinking movie this is
one that you know you got to sit and
watch and pay attention to it and
although I think although I liked it you
know I think also I think it's a little
bit more effective on a female audience
because it deals with a bunch of issues
that [ __ ] freak the [ __ ] out of women
more than a dozen yeah this movie scares
the [ __ ] out of me yeah not Satanists
yeah well the thing that's cool about
this that I think makes it scarier I
mean at least for me personally and you
know Roman Polanski did this on purpose
they actually even bought that they
bought the rights to the screenplay or
for the novel by Ira Levin which
actually I almost read the in in its
entirety again like before we did this
review I just didn't have time to finish
it but I got most of the way through it
yeah so he hadn't even finished it and
the very famous William Castle who most
people know he made like a lot of like
really cheesy movies in the 50s where he
did all those gimmicks you know to mean
like the thing where he would put the
buzzers in the seats for the Tingler and
the emerg oh thing with the skeleton
that comes out during I think it was
house on Haunted Hill or whatever it was
so that guy actually bought the rights
to Ira Levin's novel Rosemary's Baby and
wanted to make it into a movie you know
before it was even published however
like when they got the producers
the company everything I'm like yeah we
want to make this movie but we don't
really want William Castle directive
because of his reputation as kind of
like you know for making like B pictures
really so they offered a couple movies
to Roman Polanski because he had done he
wasn't like kind of a mainstream
director at this point he had done a
knife in the water I think and he had
done repulsion so he was still very much
like an arthouse director but they
thought that he could you know go on to
much greater things like more mainstream
success so they actually he was like
really excited about this movie now what
he wanted to do though and the book is
like this as well is that yes it's about
a satanic cult and in some ways it you
know if you think about it it's kind of
over the top you know the concept of it
but in execution it comes across as
completely realistic and completely
believable this movie started the
satanic panic if you ask me well it was
for sure um it was for sure responsible
for like a lot of these satanic movies
that came out yeah in you know in later
years because I mean this came out in
1968 and it was kind of like the big you
know satanic movie and it kind of kicked
off this whole big panic and Ira Levin
the guy that wrote the book he has
actually said that too that he said you
know I kind of blamed this book and the
movie for like kick-starting that whole
everyone's afraid to Satan all of a
sudden he's like you know when we
thought that that was kind of like
Satanism and like people worried about
Satanism was going away you know what I
mean it he's like and I kind of feel bad
that I kind of had a part in bringing
that back out you know yeah people
actually thought this was going on
remember I was growing up you know
watching Geraldo Rivera and all those
damn daytime talk-show [ __ ] that you
could you could watch you know during
the summer vacation and you know they
they were they were awesome because they
would cover paranormal topics and stuff
you know I'm not gonna I'm not they knew
how to entertain a daytime it's like
they were complete [ __ ] but it was
entertaining bullsh yeah but they would
have any fun saying they came out of
satanic breeding programs that you know
girls are saying yeah I was in a breeder
program I gave birth baby to a hundred
babies and they killed them all you know
it was it was so [ __ ] over-the-top
and bizarre that me as a kid might start
a thing with me
something like that might might be real
yeah yeah me especially after you know
that mom poltergeist [ __ ] that happened
to me I was thinking maybe maybe they
are doing that but FBI was coming out
going no there's no evidence for any of
this these people are full of [ __ ] yeah
and like the thing is it's like and we
talked about this a long time ago look
on our second show the satanic yeah
weird weird cult yeah there's like there
were looks like every now and then but
it's this big widespread thing and like
they're killing all these babies and
people are keeping it - yeah there's
just no way that anybody and cops and
politicians involved up to the very top
you know pedophile rings maybe but
satanic cults know maybe a pedophile
ring that kind of called itself safety
summit Clint you know there was some
weird [ __ ] that went in and what was
going on in churches like you know this
[ __ ] was documented like remember that
Catholics that Catholic school filled
with those Catholic school girls where
the yeah priests were pimping out the
girls I mean that was who the cops yeah
that really happened yes that did but
the keepers yeah that was on Netflix I
was out never but that's not that's not
the same as a satanic cult [ __ ]
breeding kids and weird [ __ ] was going
on but not exactly as told in these
stories yeah yeah and like I said it
seems like Rosemary's Baby when it was
published because it was published in
1967 and then the movie was made and in
1968 cause like I said the rights of it
were purchased before it was even
published you know what I mean so I feel
like this did kind of kick off the whole
thing you know later on that blood on
Satan's claw they had the exercise the
The Omen later on like all these kind of
satanic movies that came out in the 70s
and but like I said the thing about this
and the thing that makes it work and
what makes it scarier to me I mean one
I've always been a big I mean I'm not a
fan of Roman Polanski as a person
because obviously he kind of sucks but
as a filmmaker I mean I love his [ __ ]
particularly his early stuff and he was
just really really good at putting
across this atmosphere of just like
dread and paranoia and this kind of like
ambiguity where it's like you know and
particularly in Rosemary's Baby
you know we talked about a little bit
more we're talking about the tenant to
where you've not really entirely sure
cuz Rosemary's Baby is pretty much it's
entirely from Rosemary's point of view
so you only know what rosemary knows you
know what I mean like you don't know
about like the machinations like going
on behind the scenes or anything like
that so it's almost kind of like you're
with her you sympathize with her you
empathize with her you want her to be
right but then there's like a little
thing in the back of your mind go and
she does kind of sound crazy though a
little bit in a little way there gasps
like the [ __ ] out of this girl oh my god
and this was like every time I watch
this movie cuz weak Netflix just added
it like not too long ago and that's what
I was like Oh finally like you know I
don't want to do this for a really long
time
and every time I see this movie and I
have to say this is actually one of the
most faithful book to movie adaptations
I've ever seen Roman Polanski adapted
the novel and he had never adopted
adapted someone else's work before so he
didn't know that you could like change
it yes so he pretty much made it exactly
say so if you read the book there's like
in whole and scenes whole chunks of
dialogue are like exactly like the movie
it was just some stuff that was taken
out because of her length I would I'm
Anton LaVey claims to be in this movie
he claimed to be he claimed to play the
devil he was in the devil costume yeah
they came and got it got room yeah so
see I wonder if he just said that or if
he just said that so he'd be like I
don't like the guy in the Eddie Murphy
movies yeah works with Roman Polanski
even though he put and wait it was when
we watched Rosemary's Baby I said that's
the guy that's him he's the elevator
elevator I'm here
I think it's been confirmed that that
Anton LaVey did some concert consulted
maybe I'm not sure if he consulted on
Rosemary's Baby he did consult on our
know Devil's rain Devils Ryan Devil's
rain he was in The Devil's where I think
he also consulted for the the car he
might have yeah I think was said so in
the credits yeah but he did he did
devil's rain was William Shatner and I
see he played like very pretty you had
like eye candy or something like that
they show him like we did a show on
Anton aunt's house he was funny he's
[ __ ] but yeah so the the one thing
and the thing that scares me the most
about this movie is
that you know poor little rosemary who
all she wants is she wants this really
nice apartment you know she's a
homemaker and everything like that her
hardl husband guy is an aspiring actor
and he's been in some commercials and
[ __ ] like that but he's not you know
super famous or anything like that but
he wants like a big break and he keeps
looking for a big break but you know
she's so and says she's like oh she
wants to start a family and she wants
and in a way they go into this a little
bit more in the book but it's kind of
like a dress in the movie she is a
small-town girl she's from Omaha
Nebraska she comes from a very large
Catholic family and she says that she's
agnostic now and stuff like that but you
can tell that not really that there's a
lot of that Catholic kind of [ __ ] going
on still back there so that kind of
plays into the whole story too because
here's this small-town girl who's living
in New York City you know in with all
these theater people and stuff like that
she's trying to be very sophisticated in
stuff but she's really like kind of a
farm girl at heart and she kind of wants
to I mean she wants like the Family
Values dream you know what I mean she
just wants like a pretty house she wants
the babies she wants all that kind of
stuff and in a way like the satanic cult
headed by their their wacky old
neighbors Berman and Minnie castevet are
kind of like almost like exploiting that
and subverting her desires you know what
I mean for that and so in a way like
rosemary is obviously and if you see in
the movie like Rosemary's not their
first choice to birth the son of Satan
they actually were grooming one girl
named Terry who'd been staying with them
she was like a drug addict and they
fished her out of the gutter and like
got her off heroin and all this other
stuff
and she talks to rosemary very briefly
in the laundry room and she talks about
how wonderful air and stuff like that
but then like a scene or two later you
know she jumps off she jumps out the
[ __ ] window if they like the seventh
floor I think they live on the seventh
floor and kills herself and so at that
point the cult starts grooming rosemary
now like I said the great thing about
this movie and the one thing that scares
me and infuriates me an equal measure is
that it's bad enough that these [ __ ]
old people next door
who they're bullying but in a way that
the this to me like is what makes it
more insidious because they're clearly
bullying her and they're clearly
manipulating her but they're doing it in
a way that comes across as like oh
they're just being friendly and helpful
and stuff like that but like overly so
so it's like you feel bad telling them
to [ __ ] off because they seem like
they're being nice it's like oh can I do
anything for you playing my game right
and they're like bringing her stuff and
it's like and she feels bad
like not allowing them but because she
is kind of like a submissive personality
like I said maybe from her Catholic
upbringing her small-town upbringing or
whatever so they kind of just used this
niceness yeah
- like infiltrate her well I mean
they'll just like come over like mini
comes over with a friend and they're
knitting and they just like oh you don't
mind that we're here and they just come
in and like sit down on her couch and
start knitting and [ __ ] like that
it's like they just start invading like
every little aspect like yeah aunt olive
able to call that like less her satanic
mastered magic yeah that's exactly what
Robert L shook would just call it
high-pressure sales techniques that's
what you use them well that's what
they're doing you use the you use of
persons friendly nature and their good
manners against them yeah
by getting by having conversations to
filter them and channel them down to the
end result of buying something from you
and they don't realize that you're doing
it and in the end you think it's your
idea to buy this thing yeah and then and
that is essentially they think adults do
but essentially what they're doing to
her it's like they're almost like
love-bombing her right oh and it said
this happens in the media the news media
and politics so they're doing it to you
too has been whole [ __ ] books written
on propaganda and mass psychology and
manipulating [ __ ] masses so you know
don't think Oh that'll never happen to
me now they're trying to do it all the
time to you and like I said that's you
know it operations you know it's bad
enough that that you know this cult is
like manipulating her into essentially
like giving birth to Satan's child but
the shitty thing is that her husband and
she doesn't know this for quite a long
time but her husband
essentially sells out her body I mean is
what he does yeah
and he does that very early on in the
film because apparently they promised
him oh you'll get these big breaks and
stuff and I I don't think he believes
them at first but then a big part that
he's up for that went for to somebody
else then suddenly that guy goes blind
and tries to kill himself and he's like
in a mental hospital or whatever yeah
and so he gets the part and he even says
in the movie hell of a way to get it he
says that in the movie yes oh is then he
realizes he's like oh they're legit so
sure yeah it's not really clear if they
did that with some kind of supernatural
power I don't think they were I think
they were poisoning people and using you
know technology well they can tech not
technology but tactics social tactics
like gangster tactics to get this done
I'm not sure there's many natural [ __ ]
the debt that does happen at the end you
know what do you think but see I kind of
think well in a way like I said Roman
Polanski wanted this he said yes it's
about a satanic cult yes it's
supernatural but he's like I wanted to
make it completely realistic so he's
like I didn't want you to see anything
yes there was a dream sequence where she
is impregnated by Satan but it's a dream
sequence like even though you know you
suspect that it's happening in real life
and she suspects that it's happening in
real life because she's been drugged but
only partially you could write that off
as like saying oh well she just dreamed
that she just hallucinating there's
nothing nothing else supernatural but
everything is ambiguous because like I
said that guy goes blonde blind when
Rosemary's friend hutch tries to warn
her about the cult and about like roman
castevet how his name's an anagram and
all this other kind of stuff hutch
suddenly goes into a coma after they
took something of his a glove so I think
they're doing voodoo [ __ ] on people and
honestly I didn't even just didn't even
occur to me until I was rereading the
book again this morning but at the very
beginning when they're first looking at
the apartment in the Bramford which was
actually the Dakota at least the outside
was where John Lennon got shot in 1980
when they're first looking at the
apartment the guy that's showing the
apartment says Oh mrs. gardenia the
woman that used
live there she was also in a coma and
she had died and there was an
implication and I don't remember how
much of this they went into in the movie
but there was an implication that she
had had a falling out with mini castevet
and was maybe about to like narc on him
or do some other kind of [ __ ] and they
put her in a coma too so I think that
they are doing supernatural so I was
under the impression that it was kind of
like what would happen in real voodoo
like Haitian voodoo voodoo where it was
a mixture of like mind games drugs and
poisons that's how I thought it might be
because many did have like an herb
garden you know what I mean
and she was giving rosemary like a shake
like after she gets pregnant you know
that's supposed to have like vitamins
and I thought it was drugs and poisons
that they were it might be which would
kind of go to the voodoo witchcraft type
you know I mean a lot of stuff a lot of
stuff in you know old-fashioned
witchcraft you could probably kind of
like break it down to you know making
drugs out of roots and stuff get out of
it and I thought it was it maybe but
like I said they kind of dress it up
with rituals in my games and again kind
of like gangster tactics and cult
tactics you know that's what I thought
was going on but they're without a doubt
towards the end she did give birth to a
supernatural yeah there was something
wrong definitely wrong like in that
devil eyes so yeah so although they
never show in every show and I love that
was it an effect of some kind of drug
but they were giving her what she was
poison I don't know but maybe it was the
devil the whole thing is the whole thing
is written so it's like possible
deniability yeah where it could be
either which to me like I said a better
way to do it it makes it scarier because
one you're not really sure if she's
losing her marbles or not because and
the other scary thing is that after
hutch goes into a coma
I mean hutch was the only person who was
actually looking out for her and was
actually you know on her side I thought
no one else could be trusted no one
I thought they'd I thought they just
poisoned him but maybe it was
supernatural and you're not really
supposed to know yeah I don't think they
like called it one way or the other I
don't think the book does either
basically they're just like yeah they
went he went into a
this morning they don't know what's
wrong with him so it's a good flick it's
a classic
it inspired a lot of other movies I mean
you know I mean in this genre it
actually created the genre I don't think
you'd have had movies like some of the
other horror movies that came out after
it like um what am I thinking of a
medieval horror and you would I don't
think you would have had Exorcist and
[ __ ] come out without this movie well
like I said I think this really is it
kicked off and like I said IRA Levin is
even like said that like an interview is
he's passed away now but because it's
over the top topic and and problem back
in the city you wouldn't think I don't
think they thought a movie like this
would sell and then came out and they
went oh man you know people actually
really like that let's do that again
yeah so then you start to see a bunch of
satanic slash Christian themed horror
movies start coming out one after the
other yeah and people liked it but it
caused that satanic panic I believe yeah
and like I said IRA Levinson's to agree
with you that he oh he held himself
partly responsible it was him you know
for you youngsters out there there was
no internet so getting information was
hard back in those days you could only
get it from television and television
would kind of support the fact that
there were satanic cults running around
some people believed it yeah you know
Geraldo said that they were there and
there's Sally Jessy Raphael salad Sally
Jessy Raphael said the same satanic
cults were real and the news I think was
kind of saying that satanic cults are
rare because real because he'd have
serial killers and they'd show pictures
of pentagrams during the news yeah and
all the church people were saying it was
real so people thought it was real well
I think a lot of that happened and
actually let you know the book and movie
of Rosemary's Baby goes into this too
it's very much like a backdrop against
which the story is set you know they're
kind of playing with the fact that you
know in the 1960s traditional religion
was in the decline and you know there
were all these alternative belief
systems everyone was getting into like
New Age type of stuff
and I think like for more traditional
religious people that was very scary for
them and so I that you know there's
there's like kind of a backdrop of that
going on with Rosemary's Baby too
because not only her character I mean
even they mentioned this in the movie as
well there's like you know the Pope is
visiting New York City and she goes a
lot into her like Catholic background
and how there's still some of it left
over even though she says she's agnostic
and you know and so it's kind of playing
with that and it's also kind of playing
with the whole you know women's
liberation movement and so it's almost
kind of like a thing where it's a clash
between like traditional and like you
know newer you know ideas that were
coming out at the time yeah if you were
wondering how extreme could it get yeah
so you know that's where this all the
satanic [ __ ] started popping up so I
think that's kind of what makes it a
richer experience because then it can be
read like in a lot of trouble salutely
there's a lot of subtext but like I said
you don't have to take it like that you
can just take it as like kind of a
creepy like psychological drama with
some supernatural elements that aren't
super over-the-top but there's all kind
of stuff like going on under the surface
and like I said probably and the way I
usually take it too is that you know as
I said I find it so scary because it
seems so easy for rosemary to get sucked
into this thing where she's just
constantly being taken advantage of
every single thing she wants to do is
shot down you know everyone is just
forcing their will upon her and she has
lost all control of her life and of her
body you know it's being used against
her will and she can't she feels like
she can't do anything about it because
she doesn't have anyone to help her she
doesn't have this anyone to turn to this
movie reminds me a lot of the Stepford
Wives for some reason well it's the same
writer Ira Levin wrote that novel all
right yeah called it I have the ability
to do that too somehow
without even knowing who these [ __ ]
are I can recognize they're like I can
recognize their work it has a similar
tone similar satirical yeah well I think
Stepford Wives more than Rosemary's Baby
but Rosemary's Baby has almost a little
bit of a black comedy vibe to it
also in the book and for sure in the
movie and I
particularly the way they cast Ruth
Gordon who actually won an Oscar for
playing Minnie castevet she is just she
is so [ __ ] great in this because
she's like you can see how you could get
sucked into that because she is very
nice and very helpful but she's also
really nosey and she's really forthright
she's always coming over when she's not
really wanted like forcing her way in
but in a way that you feel bad telling
her to piss off I feel like you don't
want her around because then she'll be
feel like you feel guilty about it [ __ ]
like that yeah so you can see how you
know just inch by inch how Rosemary's
you know her control over her life is
just being ebbed away like very very
slowly and by the end she almost thinks
she's losing her mind and then it's like
the sad thing and this like freaks me
out really bad too it was like she goes
to you know finally she puts her foot
down because her pregnancy has been
really difficult she's losing weight she
looks terrible she looks ill you know
she has constant pain and she keeps you
know complaining about saying
something's wrong something's wrong so
it oh don't worry about it it'll go away
and all this other kind of [ __ ] so
finally she puts her foot down she
invites her friends over they tell her
go to another doctor because you know
but they've been through it so they know
that there's something wrong so they
tell her go get a second opinion this
doctor you're seeing now who was set up
by mininum Roman you know is not doing
you right so she goes back to her
initial doctor who she chose and Minnie
and castevet kind of rusted away from
her and she goes back to him and tells
him the whole thing about oats you know
I think there was satanic called she
thinks they're gonna sacrifice the baby
she doesn't understand that they're
going to you know that it's gonna be
Satan's baby she thinks they're just
gonna kill her Antichrist yeah yeah so
um well yeah that doesn't occur to her
she just she just assumes they're gonna
sacrifice it so she goes to this doctor
and this doctor her first Pete at her
first obstetrician is not in the cult
but she goes and tells him all this and
he pretends to believe her and then
[ __ ] narcs on her he calls the
husband and the other doctor and they
come and get her yeah so it's like she
literally has nobody she can trust and
that is like what's really really scary
to me yeah but another thing that I find
really interesting though is I really
like that
they ended it because she has the baby
they tried to tell her the baby's dead
but she's like she doesn't buy it
because she hears a baby crying and
there's a thing where you know they're
pumping out her milk or whatever and
they're like oh well don't put the spoon
in it that's messy and she's like well
what difference does it make if you're
just throwing it away because they told
her they just throw it away
so she eventually goes over there and
finds the baby and sees it and then
freaks out in the very famous scene
where she sees it sighs and everything
like that but then at the very end of it
she almost she decides that she's going
to mother this baby you know what I mean
so it's almost kind of like her motherly
instinct like over record like her doubt
about this whole thing I mean this is
Satan's baby this is a Satan baby she
sees it right in front of her and yet
that that maternal instinct is so strong
her Catholic upbringing is so strong
that she thinks well it's still my baby
and so I'm gonna take care of it you
know what I mean she doesn't say that
but you can try what would have things
you can just see it in her face that's
probably over there no I should say that
in I believed it was mid 70s maybe 1976
they actually made a TV movie sequel to
this called I think it's called whatever
happened to Rosemary's Baby yeah on
YouTube for free it's not very good yeah
Patty Duke is plays rosemary
she was actually supposed to play
rosemary in the original movie but then
didn't I remember the ads for it as a
kid yeah that was coming on I just
remember it being not very good I never
saw it I don't think now interestingly
in the 1990s Ira Levin wrote a novel
sequel called Sun of rosemary and it was
actually the last book he wrote I
believe he died of heart attack not too
long after it was published and don't
get me wrong I loved Ira Levin okay I've
read most of his books he's a great
fantastic writer son of rosemary made me
so angry
that when I finished it I threw it
against the wall and I have never done
that before
tough dumb it was um the ending made me
really really angry - the ending made me
really angry
yeah I won't tell you what it was the
ending prior retro actively spoils
everything that he's done
right including this movie right then
although she woke up and it was all just
a dream
uh it wasn't quite that but all that
this okay
but all those yeah alright like I can
see how like I can see how it could be
kind of divided like you might think oh
cool you know what I mean at the ending
I can see how you would think it was
cool but for me it just made me angry
okay but um yeah so a couple other
things I wanted to say about kind of the
production of Rosemary's Baby
like I said interestingly Roman Polanski
was actually gonna put Sharon Tate in
the movie or perhaps Tuesday Weld I
think was worried what he wanted to
because he actually pictured rosemary
when he was writing the adaptation as
like kind of a bigger like a
full-figured like a farm girl type of
you know like you know what I mean not
like a little waifish woman but the
thing is when he kind of went to the
producers about it they said well you
know you know you're kind of an arthouse
director this is gonna be your first
mainstream movie and the book hadn't
been published yet so it wasn't like a
big bestseller even though Ira Levin was
kind of a no-name cuz he published a few
other books before that so they're like
we kind of want a slightly bigger star
like a little bit more you know star
power just to to make sure that the
movie sells so they actually got Mia
Farrow to do it even though she was not
super famous at the time she had only
had a couple of like she'd been like in
a couple of supporting roles in films
she was kind of famous because she was
on Peyton Place on TV and also she had
just married Frank Sinatra now
interestingly and very famously Frank
Sinatra when he married Mia Farrow
he did not want her to have a film
career or an acting career because he
was that kind of guy I guess so when she
took the lead in Rosemary's Baby he was
very upset and very famously served her
with divorce papers right in the middle
of her filming a scene you want to be
married to an actress
I guess not well I don't think he wanted
her to work period yeah it was back then
yeah so also you know what was going on
in Hollywood back then you're always
casting couches and [ __ ] like that you
know see come on but she a lot of times
a lot of time actors and actresses you
know
the way they land those jobs as Harvey
Weinstein that's probably why I go ahead
yeah but so anyway she tried to kind of
patch up their relationship by saying oh
well I'll quit the movie but at this
point they had already filmed like half
of the movie and you know they were kind
of like look that they showed her a
rough cut of the movie they said look
you're so good in it you're gonna get an
Oscar it's like you know please stay
with it so she did decide to stay with
it in the end and Frank Sinatra divorced
her sadly she did not win an Oscar she
didn't get nominated although like I
said Ruth Gordon got nominated furberg
nominated for Best Supporting Actress in
one this also was nominated for Best
Adapted Screenplay which I don't believe
that it won but as I said now I I do
feel like I've seen like a lot of
younger people review this movie and a
lot of them really seem very positive
about it which that makes me happy
because sometimes I feel like movies
that came out in the sixties or
seventies you know if you didn't live
through that time period if you didn't
or if you don't have a lot of knowledge
about it like sometimes you'd be like
what's scary about that or you know I
can see how if there's like a cultural
difference or like an age difference
then maybe you can't understand like why
something is scary you know what I mean
they don't understand the context of the
time right and I'm saying to that I
particularly because Rosemary's
character I mean I don't find her
particularly I mean yes she's submissive
maybe more than a woman in a horror
movie would be nowadays but I guess the
same complaints were made about you know
Shelley Duvall in the shining and stuff
it's like oh why didn't she just like
bash him on the head with a bat and get
the [ __ ] out of there wasn't the book
but that wasn't yeah and that wasn't and
the thing about it too is that you know
there have been submissive people
throughout you know that's just like
people's person you got it was like that
today like that today so it's like I did
not find her particularly like
annoyingly submissive or anything like
that and another thing too is that you
have to think if you really thought like
your next-door neighbors were Satanists
I mean if I thought like I would think I
was crazy like oh I must be imagined in
the book she was surrounded by a bunch
of people that were much much older than
her you know they were kind of just
funneling her down into hit you
- nobody know exactly what how to do it
so you know like I said another thing is
is that we're talking about the context
of the time yeah I think a good a good
example look at what they're doing with
like the predator series they're
constantly trying to reboot the predator
over and over again hoping to get that
same thing from predator one it'll never
happen alright never happened because
everybody knows what the predator looks
like yeah now he's kind of like the best
thing about was what the prey was in
releasing that mask on that predator
came off all right for the first time
and you're sitting in that audience at
[ __ ] 17 or 18 years old and see that
face
it looks real you just bought it a
hundred percent you're like that's an
alien dad it's a funny name yep and [ __ ]
look okay anything they looked amazing
it looks amazing still it's amazing and
it was filmed and you know kind of like
an older fashioned kind of grainy film
so it wasn't real HD you couldn't see
any flaws in the costume at all it
looked like a real creature to aspect
that and that's what made that movie
it's after that reveal you could never
really recreate that again so and as of
the context of the time so you can't
come out with a new predator movie and
have anybody really be impressed with it
oh yes everybody's been seeing that [ __ ]
sending with Star Wars you try to bring
Star Wars back it's just another Syfy
show ever everything looks like that
back in the day the Star Wars the first
Star Wars came out no one had seen
anything like that yeah so I had a huge
impact so show that to a kid today and
they're just like so yeah you know so I
do feel like and and I kind of say this
with a lot of horror movies cuz I like
horror movies from like from every era I
even like silent movies like you know
from the early 1900s as long as you come
at it with some idea of like the time
you know what I mean
I think Rosemary's Baby still holds up
very well today just as kind of a study
in become and because it's not like
over-the-top paranoia or anything like
that even though yes she has a very
submissive character yes you know she is
able to be you know manipulated by
people around her but I don't think
that's really all that far-fetched er I
think it I don't think it's all that
different than what might happen to
someone today in that same situation so
I think this is actually aged fairly
well I mean you know what I mean other
than it being 1968 in the clothes and
the hair yeah that in 1968 the idea of a
satanic cult trying to breed women and
to make that that was a new concept that
was a new and terrifying concept it's
not quite as as scary as today
yeah well and it's because we've seen it
some times in part because of this movie
because a man a successful vampires are
not scary they were scary in the 1800s
that was a novel concept although that
new Dracula untold movie was quite cool
yeah bill not scary yeah and you know
well I think it may change it takes a
lot to scare people now I mean yeah
you're always gonna be able to make
something scary because you know
whatever the context of the time is
there's always some fear that people
have that you can exploit like in your
horror movies and stuff like that you
got to go as far as like making human
centipedes and [ __ ] like that that's how
far you and even that that wasn't scary
that was just like no that was just
disgusting imagine if you got caught up
in that yeah did that to you I'm still
I'm not scared of that it's just kind of
like body horror though a weird [ __ ]
like that yeah and you know it's just
weird but I mean like I said I think the
thing that still scares me about
Rosemary's Baby nowadays it's just the
idea that she's alone like everyone she
thought she could trust turned on her
essentially you know and they're just
trying to use her for their own that
without really seeming like that's what
they're doing yeah and you know it's
just it seems like this trap like just
closing tighter and tighter and tighter
and she doesn't have anybody to turn to
and the one guy that she does turn to
you that's not in the cult he doesn't
believe her yeah you know what I mean
and then he like just throws her right
back to them so to me that's what makes
this really scary and like I said it
seems like Roman Polanski was really
good particularly with his apartment
trilogy which was repulsion and the
tenant and this one of just kind of
having this ambiguous creepy you know
this this thing of like either madness
or like other people like closing in on
you and just
taking all of your agency away and I
think that that's like a really scary
concept still and I still find this a
pretty scary movie and a very
infuriating movie because like it's per
specially her husband god damn it that
guy's such a [ __ ] I ever watching it
again I'm like look at this [ __ ] aah
it's like keep it like five minutes
after they moved into the [ __ ]
apartment building he's over there at
the old neighbors and they're like hey
want your wife to birth Satan's babies
like for a film role sure just have at
it
raper while she's sleeping why not you
know what I mean it's like it's just
what what a [ __ ] head yet but that like
scare the crap out of me but yeah so for
real if you haven't seen Rosemary's Baby
again what the hell is the matter with
you it's a classic of cinema and you
should definitely check it out the book
is also very good although like I said
the movie in the book are very similar
I'm not saying that you shouldn't read
the book if you've seen the movie
because obviously you should always read
the book but because the book goes into
like a few more things and like in into
like Rosemary's like internal monologue
and stuff like that and has like a
couple other subplots that were left out
of the movie but other than that were
you know pretty similar so if you like
the book like the movie you should
probably like the book as well so that
will do it for our breakdown up
Rosemary's Baby and we will see you next
time bye